yeah Sasha last night work began on the
Northbound Lane here on the I-15 just a
little bit down the road as you can see
for one mile between the 95 and
Washington Avenue this work will last
all weekend up until 5 a.m on Monday
then starting July 7th more work
continues as both directions of I-15
will be reduced to one lane at Lake Mead
Boulevard that will end the morning of
July 10th here's what a motorcyclist had
to say about how the construction in the
area has affected his driving
I think they shouldn't played a
splitting Lane for us because in
California they can split Lanes here you
can't but it's kind of difficult with
the road construction as far as being a
rider and then you know we always have
to be conscious of other cars trying to
get in
last lastly on
Angel Queen Washington Avenue and the 95
for one mile like today but that's going
to be the southbound lane Crews will
work on the I-15 bridges over Washington
Avenue in addition to D Street F Street
Bonanza Road and the upper railroad
tracks ndot stating that these Lane
restrictions are necessary to install a
bond overlay thus enhancing the traction
on the roads then you're also extending
the lifespan of the paving on these
Bridges reporting here near the I-15 in
Washington Madison Kimbrough 8 News
[Music]